Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday, December 18th, 2017.
What's going on? How are
Ya? How you doing? How are
Yay, look at you over there.
You look good. You look
good. Um, I, you know,
a lot of people probably think I'm in a
great mood with that patriots' victory,
uh, yesterday, which is actually today
cause I'm recording at night, but uh,
I just had what can they
fix that fucking rule.
Okay.
That's it. It's a catch. You caught the
fucking ball. You're ran with the ball.
You stick it over the goal line.
It's a fucking touchdown.
Dez Bryant, few years ago, fucking
touchdown. The week before that,
whoever the fucking cowboys played,
was it the lions?
They should have won that game. I,
I don't, I don't fucking get it.
I don't understand how that rule is
supposed to make it less confusing.
Nobody even touched the guy.
He had control of the ball.
I, I don't like the ground.
Can't cause a fumble,
but it can cause an incomplete pass.
It can break up a pass.
So it only if you're a receiver do
you get fucked over by the ground?
But if you're a running back,
you're in the clear does
that how it works daddy?
They made a football move.
I'll tell you,
that's going to be the last one.
Did they?
They're going to have to adjust it.
That rule during the off season.
They have to fix it cause that
was for home field advantage, um,
throughout the playoffs. That
was fucking huge. And uh,
it's a fucking amazing game.
Amazing fucking game. Right?
I think we both can agree with
that on both sides. And by the way,
conti ass fucking Steeler fans.
Remember I'm saying this shit for one.
The pendulum swings your fucking way.
All right.
I hate why he would fucking,
when I hate those sports fans where
if there's a bullshit call in in a,
it goes your way.
Yo Bro.
That's like that 50 year old guy banging
an 18 year old girl was, you know,
I just know scumbag Arry going on there.
Um,
yeah, that, that, I dunno, that
whole fucking thing was just like,
I'm trying to remember what happened.
At the end of the game. Okay.
The game starts off great. I know. I'm
going to say the guy's fucking name wrong.
I've been too fucking busy. But, uh,
seeing Ryan Shazier is NSA Shazier,
you know,
at the game,
that was great to see.
And he looked like he was in great
spirits and I was looking up like, like,
I don't know if you guys know this,
but like paralysis is a major
fucking like phobia, you know,
like when people go, I don't want to
be burned at death. Like my thing is,
is just fucking laying there
and not being able to move. Um,
I dunno like that, that just seems
like the worst, I don't know,
worse than fucking death.
So to see the tech guys getting feeling
in his legs and that type of stuff was,
I don't, I'm just some weird selfish
way. It was like a relief to me.
Probably should have thought of him first,
but I'm a selfish cunt living in
Hollywood and that's why the good lord is
burning it down. Um, no, let's,
let's even mean you know what,
you know what it was. I actually
felt great for the guy, but I,
I grew up in such a fucked up part
of the world that actually me saying
something nice about him.
I got, I get weirded out.
So then I had to be a dick
throughout all of that. So anyways,
what I'm trying to say is I'm really
happy that that guy looks like he's going
to be okay. Okay. That's
what I was trying to say.
So it starts off with that and then
it's going to be another classic Patriot
Steeler battle, which it was,
we missed an extra point.
Is that going to come back to haunt us?
There's no way this game could go into
overtime. That's what I'm thinking.
And then all of a sudden
to the steel has had the fucking game
one who's kitten Ho and then the last two
possessions before we went
with the go ahead score,
they kind of fucking played the
little alligator arm ball. Right.
Which allowed us to get back in it.
Then Brady threw an interception,
but the guy dropped it.
Sorry, the guy drops the ball.
This is what I can remember the
dewdrop drop the fucking ball.
That was the end of the game.
And then Tony Romo goals yet though.
I get the chance.
Was it basically what I was saying,
we go down the field,
Brady to Gronk Brady to Gronk Brady
Brady to Gronk touchdown two point
conversion Brady to Gronk
go fuck yourself. All right.
Okay.
That was like when Batman and Robin and
the TV show would be stuck in a fucking
trap. You know what I mean?
And they, we ended the episode,
lots of that for the cake crusade.
Then all of a sudden they break out and
they beat the fuck out of everybody,
right?
That was the football version of that.
Okay.
So then there's 50 something seconds
left and now I'm not feeling comfortable
cause they got fucking Big Ben and they
have this great field goal kicker and I
know that everybody's going to go into
the fucking whatever the fuck they went
into, whatever that defenses that
makes everybody look like Joe Montana,
including fucking, uh, Jimmy
Garappolo out there in San Francisco.
I love how both quarterbacks,
who's The fucking guy in Tennessee?
Is it Vinny Testaverde? Is he
still playing? Uh, Mike Moriarty?
What the fucks, I can never remember
his name. The kid from Oregon,
he marches down the field,
go ahead. Score, you know,
against their fucking end of the game.
So now we don't play defense.
So I guess the ratings
increase is that what happens?
Okay.
Right. They go ahead and when
they go for the go ahead score,
then fucking 49 is get the ball back or
they just marched right down the goddamn
field. The old right there, Fred. Um,
anyways,
yeah.
So it was like 56 seconds left.
What the fuck?
Just don't let them get out of bounds.
Give him the middle of the field.
I guess that's what they try to do. And
what do we do? What the fuck did we do?
How many times is our defense going to
do this to Tom Brady after he wins a
fucking game? God knows we did it twice.
Playing the giants and the Superbowl. Tom,
terrific.
As Paul Versey calls them,
goes down the fucking field
and for the go ahead score,
all that defense has to do is stop them.
Sanjay Samuel drops the fucking ball.
Uh,
anyways, I don't know what the fuck. Let
me, let me, let me stay on this year here.
So I don't know what this
fucking defense is going to do.
So for whatever fucking reason,
Ben Roethlisberger
fucking throws.
What was,
it was at a screen pass that
goes for 69 fucking yards.
It was like the guide.
It was like the,
all of a sudden we turned to look
at a third grade pop Warner team.
Two guys bump into each other and the
dude continues on down the fucking
sideline.
Now that down at the 10 yard line and all,
I'm thinking, well the very least this
is going to go into fucking overtime,
right?
Ben goes back to pass, throws it
to the fuck. Was it a white dude?
I don't even remember. Everything
happened so fast. He caught the ball.
He goes in touchdown, right? Well,
they've got to look to see
if his knees down hair.
I can't believe. I cannot fucking
believe they called that back.
Okay.
What more do you have to
do to establish possession?
He's got the ball.
Is he supposed to stop with 10 seconds
left and hold it up to the ref?
This is a football,
I have it in my hands to try to run it in.
The guy did exactly what the fuck he
was supposed to do. He caught the ball,
headed to the end zone,
reached out and score.
They took it away from
him. Then I think the, uh,
you know,
this is when it comes down to coaching
and this is why the Patriots win these
Games is that when they fucking
call the fucking touchdown back,
it didn't look like the fucking
Steelers knew what they wanted to do.
I don't know what the hell that was
and I'm just basically telling
you what the fuck you saw. Um,
cause I'm doing it Sunday night.
I still can't believe that we,
not even that we won the game.
I can't believe that that
wasn't a catch and a touchdown.
I don't know what else you have to do.
Okay.
To show a possession.
You know what,
I'm to them for like the 19th
time on this fucking podcast.
I'm going to look up this
rule and I'm going to read it.
Reading NFL rules is is
it's like reading the Bible.
It's like what are they about?
Yeah.
Alright. Nfl. That's why you have
a preacher for all the dummies out.
Like I actually,
do you mind times?
I've sat down when I was younger
and I tried to read the Bible.
Okay.
It's like don't kick. Can
we, can we update this shit?
Can we put it in in some, in,
in just some language that
I can understand cause it
might as well be in Latin.
I don't know what anybody's talking about.
Just know there's a lot of murder
incest in the beginning. It's just like,
I don't want to see the end of this movie.
All right.
Nfl Rule
and that felt real catching pass.
Yeah.
How many people look completing a catch?
Okay,
what in the fuck do you have to do?
All right.
A player who makes a catch
may advance the ball.
I'm aware of that a Ford pass is,
it is complete by the offense or
interceptor intercepted by the defense.
If a player who is inbounds number one,
secure is control of the ball in his
hands or arms prior to the ball touching
the ground.
Okay.
Which I felt that guy did see.
The thing is you have to know what
they consider securing the ball.
I think he was supposed
to hold it like an infant
and two touches the ground
in bounds with both feet. Oh.
At any part of his body and others had
that was not pluggable to this. All right.
Well I mean, yeah, I guess it's applicable
to every catch it, but it wasn't.
There was no out-of-bounds issue.
Here's what I'm saying.
Number three maintains control of the
ball after a and B have been fulfilled
until he has the ball long enough
to clearly become a runner.
That's another weird thing. It's like
he's running while he catches it,
he's a runner.
The whole fucking play.
What we mean is running in full possession
of the ball after fulfilling the the
requirements of number one and number two.
I'm a player,
has the ball long enough to
become a runner when after
his second foot is on the
ground,
he is capable of avoiding or warding
off in pending contact of an opponent.
Okay.
What if it's a bang bang play
I guess then it's not a catch.
Well I guess they call that all the
time. Okay. Comma, tucking the ball away,
turning up field or taking additional
steps. So that's what happens at,
I think at the goal line is when you're
that close and there's that little time
left, you don't have time and
you're fallen to the ground,
you don't have time to Tuck the ball away.
Okay.
They okay.
They have to put something here for this
goal line shit or first her first down
situations where
they have to be able to understand that
somebody is reaching the ball forward to
either get a first down or a touchdown.
Maybe that's what it is.
So I guess because didn't
Tuck the ball the way.
If a player has control of the ball,
a slight movement of the ball would
not be considered a loss of possession.
He must lose control of the ball in order
to rule that there has been a loss of
possession,
so he has to establish
control and then lose control.
If the player loses the
ball while simultaneously
touching both feet or any part
of his body to the ground,
it's not a catch. All right,
so both feet were on the ground so they
thought he lost control of the ball or
never had it to begin with despite the
fact that he caught it and then turned up
field for those finals,
whatever,
three yards saw the goal line,
took the ball in,
reached over the fucking goal line.
I just feel like for me, when you
fucking have the ball and you're like,
if he wasn't in control,
he wouldn't have done something like that.
He wouldn't be going like Wah Wah,
like fucking he at that time at the
fucking juggling the fucking thing.
MMM.
All right.
End Zone catches for the requirement for
a catch in the end zone or the same as
the requirements for a catch in the
field of play. Note in the field of play,
if a catch of a Ford Pass
has been completed after
which contact by a defendant
causes the ball to become loose
before the runner is down by contact,
it is a fumble and the ball remains alive.
That all makes sense. In the end zone,
the same action is a touchdown because
the plays automatically. Oh, okay.
I understand that.
That makes sense.
Okay.
All right.
Four ball touches ground.
If the ball touches the ground after
the players secures control of it,
it is a catch provided. The player
continues to maintain control. All right,
so they didn't think he either
secured or had control of it.
So what constitutes having control
of it or securing the ball?
Jesus fucking Christ. I mean dd you feel
any closer to having an answer for that?
I don't. Um, anyways,
so here's a bright side.
If you're a Steeler fan.
MMM.
In this weird way.
I was kind of hoping the Patriots were
going to lose that game even though we
would have to play you guys in Pittsburgh.
I just feel like both teams are so evenly
matched that is going to be very hard
for one of the two teams to beat each
other twice to sweep the other teams.
So I was thinking like,
well,
if we lose then Bella check is going to
figure out what they're fucking doing
and then he'll correct it and
he's done that time and again,
and he will avenge the loss and God knows
we've gone into Pittsburgh enough time
in one there. So we know we
can do that. But now, I dunno,
I dunno about this one.
I Dunno.
Like,
uh, that was just a
weird, it's just a fun,
it was just a weird ending to
a game. Okay. And all of that.
What's going to be forgot is that we
gave up 69 yards on a fucking screen pass
at the end of the fucking game
and should a lost, but we did.
So now we're going to be
home. I Dunno. I Dunno.
That was a,
that was weird.
That was a weird one.
Uh,
that was just a weird one.
But thank God in Pittsburgh they've gone
back to back with Stanley Cups. Okay.
So they can fucking,
uh,
they can stick both those in their ears
so they don't want to listen to dead
fucking crying in the other room. I don't
know what to tell you guys. That was,
you know,
I dunno.
I am now fascinated with this.
I am officially after,
this is the third time I've seen a
team get fucked over on a touchdown or
winning the game.
I have to figure out what the fuck.
Okay.
When, when did do you like
tucking the ball away?
Like there's so many times when you say
fourth and a couple of yards where you
have to catch and people are coming in,
you've got to grab it and fucking
reach forward to get a first down.
I Dunno, I have no idea.
But you know, it's funny.
On Twitter they were blaming the
patriots like some outlets are shit,
you know.
Okay
packers, you know, you could shit
on the packers, couldn't you?
Then they benefit from that cowboy
has benefited and got fucked.
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
Somehow I know it will somehow go back
to deflate gate and somehow it will go
back to that shit once again. You know
what I mean? I swear to God. Um, anyways,
plowing ahead. I just got back from
Orlando, Florida in Fort Lauderdale,
Florida. Uh, two of the most
fun shows I had this year. Um,
just great crowds. I was down
there with a forest Shah and um,
it's great pan of Jag. I,
I'm just not drinking dude.
So I'm getting up early.
I've been practicing my drums,
kind of hard to practice drums now when I,
uh,
it's just like when we edit a lot of
the times my daughter's up and then the,
the one window I have to play is like
this time at night right now when she goes
to go to sleep. So I can't
be a Douche, so I don't, uh,
not playing as much as I
would like to play. But I saw,
I watched two amazing
documentaries on Netflix.
MMM.
I was embarrassed by my,
I'll show you. You know,
do you guys know like on
your Netflix homepage,
like everybody's homepage is different
because they sort of watch what you watch.
They have like this fucking thing
and then like whatever you're into,
you know what I mean? You guys, why am I
going to explain to people how it works?
You know how it fucking works.
Everybody's is different.
So what mine became was
everything that I was watching.
See now it's cool again.
But what it was before was everything
was just fucking drug cartels behind the
scene.
Prison Shit.
MMM.
What else did the head, it was all just,
yeah, it was just all shit like that.
And then, yeah, it was just all prisons,
drug dealers, people getting killed,
all of this shit.
So I watched two fucking documentaries,
like as I got, I got, I got,
I got to watch some other shit too to
switch this up a little bit. And, um,
I watched the John Coltrane documentary
and then I watched one called,
uh,
I called him Morgan,
which is about this trumpet player
that I had never heard of before called
[inaudible] guy's name
was lead Morgan. And, um,
I cannot tell you how great a player the
guy is and it's an amazing documentary.
Really sad too. But uh,
but since I did that,
I watched two things with black people
in it. I now have a thing, Nat King Cole,
they got, she's gotta have it up here
is something about Richard Pryor,
but I also got better call Saul.
You know what I mean?
There's a way to do this because you're
gonna miss all this other cool shit if
you just keep going down the
rabbit hole watching the same shit.
I got to Jimi Hendrix thing,
I got the Jerry Seinfeld comedian.
I got one of the star wars movies.
Something about Mike Tyson, right?
I think it's funny they got that whole
something on Jacko. Pistorious it's,
and he says fucking named World War
Two when color right. There you go.
No more prison shit.
This is great.
Perfect pulp fiction. I like it now.
It was going too far. The other,
the other direction like,
oh this is all this guy wants to see.
Cause I watched this thing, they
will like, you know, before,
never seen behind the scenes in a Russian
prison and they would show in these
guys.
And I'm as bad as the prison was.
What's great about it was,
is if you commit a bad enough crime,
you don't have to worry about getting
raped. Guess they don't leave me alone.
They're staring at your 24 fucking seven.
Um,
I didn't watch it that long enough.
All I know is the crimes these guys
committed was so fucking horrific.
And then they cut to the, um,
the, the warden and he goes,
I have no sympathy for these people
whatsoever. And I was just like, yeah,
neither do I.
This guy killed the whole family and
then like took their bodies out in the
woods and fucking lit them on fire. And
it's just like, yeah, fuck that guy.
And the guy sitting there going,
you know,
you gotta be really strong mentally
here, Rah Rah, you're not gonna make it.
And it's just like, I
hope you don't. I, yeah.
So I watch 10 minutes of it and I agreed
with the warden and I shut it off and
then I just looked my page at that
point and that's all it was. Um,
but anyways, I got to tell you that, um,
Lee Morgan was a guy I believe.
Who did he start out with?
I watched so much shit this weekend.
The fuck did he started out with,
he started with felonious monk.
I can't remember.
He played a little bit with John
Coltrane and then he got into a,
with Art Blakey, the Jazz messengers,
and then he went out on his own.
But like his playing is just,
he sees one of the guys, you know what
I mean? I don't know. Like, you know,
like guitar players,
there's a bunch of guys that can fucking
shred and then there's the guy that
makes you fucking hair stand up on your
arm. Like that guy's one of the guys.
He's that with the trumpet. The name of
the thing is called, I called him Morgan,
I forgot what the John Coltrane was,
but the cold train one was
on a whole other level where,
uh, it actually makes you
want to be a better person.
That's the only way to describe it.
His fucking worldview was
incredible and I didn't,
I didn't know a lot about them. You know,
I'm the typical John Coltrane hacky fan.
Like I have a love supreme, you know,
but I should get all those other ones,
blue train and all that
type of stuff. But, um,
I always went down the miles Davis,
uh,
road work, wherever he went,
whoever he played with,
I just kind of followed all the way
through that. And I know Coltrane was,
was with them twice.
Um,
he got fired one time and the
second time he left. And uh,
so then I just followed
miles into his second, uh,
was a quartet or quintet, I think quintet.
And that's the one with Tony Williams.
And then I just
stayed with Tony Right through
lifetime and all the shit he was doing.
And I kind of missed all those other guys.
So I'm finally going back and
listening to all these guys and that,
that fucking music is incredible.
It's fucking incredible. And the way
they shoot it in the black and white,
when you see the video and stuff,
it's unbelievable.
And there's this weird thing where you
wouldn't think with jazz is like a danger
to it, but there's like a
fucking edge to it that is a,
I dunno, it's compelling. And I just,
I wish they had more
documentaries like that on a,
on Netflix or if people know or
some other streaming services,
some shit where I can watch
it because, uh, I would watch
of about anybody from that.
And then I ended up finding out by Shelly,
is it Shelly Mann? A Shelly
main, he's a famous, um,
jazz drummer,
a white dude.
And through watching the Coltrane thing,
I saw the played a Gig and he had this,
this Shelly Mann had this place called
sh Shelly Mann's manhole is Shelley's
manhole or something like that.
And I was sitting there going like,
I wonder where that it,
that that was in la because
nothing has ever preserved in la.
And,
uh,
I found out that it's right on
cove whanga just north of sunset,
right around the corner from big Wang's
where I used to go there all the time
before I was married and
watch games and all that shit.
And I just was thinking like
miles Davis, John Coltrane,
all these monster fucking players
all
played live right around the corner
for where me and my friends were
like 50 years later gone dude all day.
Like how much that blocked
dropped off. Uh, but, uh,
very announced La thing.
I guess there's some sort of commemorative
thing to that jazz club in the
sidewalk. They're like, I'm
not like a star or anything,
but I thought that was pretty
cool. So anyways, all right,
so there's that checkup,
both those documentaries,
if you're into that type of shit.
And I know I'm all over the map
here. A little music, little sports,
maybe I'm a little law.
Maybe this is a nice little fucking
balance here for once. Um, all right.
I do have some sad news here
and this really is sad news. Uh,
I lost another advertiser. Now, if
you're a fan of the podcast, you know,
this shit happens all the fucking
time to me. All right? There's a,
there's people that, you know,
they don't quite appreciate the,
my colorful way that I try
to sell the products. Um,
but these people,
they hung in there for a long time and
they finally had enough of me and I just
want to thank them for being on the
podcast. I had a great time reading their,
their copy,
a farewell to Sherry's berries.
Evidently I finally went too far where
I somehow made a clan reference while
reading about chocolate
covered strawberries.
I thought it was funny,
you know,
I was with Harris standing. He, you know,
I guess if I was by myself and I made
the claim reference, it would seem weird,
but, uh, I was in the room
with another black guy,
not another black guy with the black guy.
Right. With another guy who was black.
That's how I was trying to say.
Right.
So then obviously it doesn't
then obviously mean that
I'm just fucking around.
I don't know.
I had a great time reading your shit.
You're definitely welcome back.
Anytime.
Anytime he'd like to come back,
we'd love to have you back.
I love reading your copy. You
fucking striver is a delicious. Um,
but I get it. You know what I mean? It's
a very sensitive time out there. We have,
we have to really be conscious of what
we're affiliated 80 their archive fit bed.
The Grand Dragon starts fucking order
in some goddamn strawberry. Reese,
I don't know. I don't know what
people in advertising or, um,
you know what their problem is, is they're
trying to please everybody, you know?
And if they would just collectively,
if they could just grow a dick in some
fucking balls and just be happy with
selling strawberries or nature's box or
whatever the fuck it is. You're blue,
you're blue apron. All these people
who fucking walked off this podcast.
If you would just focus on the phone,
all the money that you, you know.
Okay.
Do you know what I would be like if I
tried to make everybody laugh? Yeah.
I, I would, I wouldn't have a puppet. I
don't know why that would have, I would,
I would, I would, I would work totally
clean. I way I would not saying any,
having a puppets bad, not saying
working clean is bad, but I would just,
I would stop
you step.
What happens is,
what happens is basically you step outside
yourself and then you start watching
yourself thinking what did they want?
And then the second you do that shit you
had done. All right, so Sherry's berries,
I think you're making a
terrible mistake here, you know,
but I'm letting you know
the door is always open.
I'll let you back in like a battered wife.
You know,
when a bad fucking relationship,
I'll let you back in and
then you can try to fuck.
You know what's funny about
these advertisers? They
always want to talk to me.
And there's the rule on the podcast
is I don't talk to any of them. Okay?
I'm not talking to you this,
this is just some bullshit I do
to make people fucking laugh for,
to promote my gigs.
Okay?
I'm not gonna Start Having fucking
conference calls about chocolate covered
fruit. There's only so many
hours in the day, you know.
Anyways, I'm happy trails guys. All
right, I'll still order your strawberries.
No hard feelings. All right.
Okay, man. Crate everybody,
man. Great. Oh, you know what? These
sons of guns, they send me the night.
These sons of bitches.
I said sons of guns.
Cause I was fucking thinking
about old. Ooh. Oh, whoa.
Don't fuck dumb. Don't offend
the strawberry people. Um,
man crates,
uh,
these sons of bitches sent me,
they sent me a bunch of bows.
They sent me all this cool grill stuff.
It actually comes in a crate.
You feel like a man when you
open it up, it's fantastic. Um,
I can't row.
I can't recommend this enough.
Now I'm not saying that I'm not going to
make a clan reference or anything like
that when I'm selling this stuff.
Oh, look who's here. Look who's here.
Was I too loud?
No, no, no.
Just close it.
Close the door the whole way.
The baby down. You're going
to call who? The decorator.
Who's the decorator.
Oh, all right. Come on now.
Can we come here? Do you?
Do you know you no
normal Sherry's berries.
I know you burn that bridge.
Maybe I didn't burn a bridge.
It was a fucking bridge was
on fire when they got there.
I did the, I did the we. You're such a
bad boy. I'm not saying it like that.
I'm saying like what I meant by that.
He's such an asshole. Why
did I marry you? What's,
why did I marry you?
I always know when you're full of
shit because you were in la. Yeah.
What I meant was I was already doing this
shit when they got with me. [inaudible]
don't try to change me.
Sherry's berries. This,
this is, this is right here that
you're a dangerous, calm, make.
You never know what's going to
come out of your mouth. Ooh.
What's he going to say now?
He's so edgy and controversial.
I'm not. You are and
you're not. You love it.
You love being like the outlier
of the whole thing, don't you?
You love it admitted. No, I just know
what I'm doing. I know what I'm doing.
Okay.
What are you doing?
I'm fucking reading advertising
and people don't want to hear it.
So you're trying to make it fun with
it so you can, the show doesn't stop.
You just keep fucking around with
these fucking dopes. Who Sold Shit.
Understood that for two
seconds. Everybody. All of
these other fucking podcasts,
you know what to do. They press fast
forward. They blow right through it.
[inaudible]
okay. It fucking works. Yeah, right?
Yes. It's a little late for that.
Now that you trash me,
you trust me down. Yeah.
Well you'll be okay.
Oh yeah.
What are you doing? Yeah,
we're on a podcast. I can't
listen to her crying. I know.
That's the hardest thing is when you
send them down, they're totally fine.
They just crying and they're trying to
get you to pick them up and you can't
fucking do it. Um,
anyways. Sleep training.
All right, we ready here now that you
fucking dressed me down here. K Net.
You Want Nia? I will. I want you to read
this copy straight. Sure. Let's see.
Let's say if you can do it. I can.
I can totally do it. You want a bed?
No, I mean you can do it. I
just wasn't trying to be like
that, but go ahead. Do it.
Okay.
Okay
man. Great. It's hard to
pick out the perfect gift,
but all too easy to get it totally wrong.
I liked that.
They think fear right under the bat.
Huh?
Nobody didn't curse. I didn't curse.
That wasn't what I was talking about.
I wasn't talking about you. Beads of
sweat forming on your forehead. Oh my God.
You can't get man crate somehow.
Solve this solution. Do it.
I can't do it. Let's go. Let's
go. This is how I watch TV.
I it's interactive introducing and
they sent me all this cool shit.
Introducing man,
crate.com the surest way
to find awesome gif gifts.
Guys will love guaranteed this isn't a
lame cheese of the month club or a new
tie man.
Okay man.
Crate offers awesome gifts for every type
of man from the rugged outdoorsman to
this sports fanatic and everything in
between. I'm sorry, that's a small window.
If you're got to go rugged outdoorsman,
you should only two types of guys. One.
Now. They did say everything in
between, but those are the two. The
two ends. Well I guess if you
go hunting, if you go hunting,
you don't really watch
football, dude. I don't know.
I don't do either of those things. What
animal could you shoot? None of 'em.
What animals do you eat?
Oh, I eat all of them.
I mean I eat the ones that you can eat.
So you're sorta like a Mafia don.
Just having everybody do
all your hits for you.
The only animals that I can kill our
end sucks. And I would kill a possum.
You know a lot of work. Parts of
the worlds that eat insects. Yeah.
Source of protein.
I kill them.
I could eat somebody else's
around the world. Gone.
That's a nice little Jalapeno popper
spider there that you could have fucking
yeah, I read it in deep fried. Awesome.
Cause that's my least favorite animal.
I could also kill a raccoon
cause I also don't like them.
You don't like varmints environments?
No. And I don't feel like a black.
You sending me Sam with a pussy. Who? Yo,
you're a female black. You
sending me? Sam, you don't
remember you little varmint.
Remember that is fucking red mustache
should be flying around hard zone. Mm.
Yeah.
Can you finish this advertising
like the Whiskey,
whiskey appreciation Craig,
but they personalize laser etched decanter
and glasses for his favorite drink
and the grill master Craig with a brass
knuckle meat tenderizer in a cast iron
smoke box smoker box. It's
a funny word. Smoker box.
Say it three times fast.
Smokers, what is the smoker box?
They three tests smuggle back smoking
pot smoker box. Oh, you did it good. Um,
just go to man crate.com. Pick up the
perfect, great. Choose your delivery date.
When his man create arrives,
he'll be the envy.
I just picture somebody
scratching as Paul's.
He'll be the envy of every guy in the
room as he pries open the bad boy with the
opening with his own
laser engraved crowbar.
They have thousands of five star reviews
and every man Craig comes with their
high five guarantee up on the holidays.
Go Mag crates,
dotcom slash and that's why they listen
slash burner to get 5% off your order.
They don't offer this discount
anywhere else. That's 5% off, man.
crates.com/bird man crates,
dotcom. Slash bar. Wait,
can we talk about what men, when a
man crate is, they give you a crowbar,
a personalized crowbar?
Yeah.
I like the kind of crowbar that you
like break into a car with. That's what,
why would you do that?
Isn't that what auto thieves use?
Crowbars how would you know
that? I wouldn't, I'm too,
I just, from the movies,
do they use what movies? Crowbars do you
break into cars when I'm on the road? No,
no, no, but isn't that a thing
that you use a crowbar to?
Like Jimmy the oh boy. Wait, yeah,
take the crowbar and you
slide it in between the door
and the window. Yeah. Yeah.
He just sorta just sort
of slipped that in there.
Do you know what a crow bar looks
like? Um, is there like a ranch?
Like a big, it's, you can't,
that's not what they use.
I don't want to fat shame a crowbar,
but it can not fit.
It cannot fit in that little area.
There. You have a little of this,
the little slim. Yeah, no, that's, what
do they call it thing? This is a slim Jim.
A little fucking thing.
You just go down there and they just
fucking know there's always there.
It looks like he's jerking off.
Was it crowbar used for?
It's used to open man crates
and regular crates to,
what about lady crates?
Do they have a lady grapes too?
I Dunno what they are.
It's probably vibrates to crop it.
Sorry. All right. Dollar Shave Club.
Dollar Shave Club.
Doe.
What you might not know is that dollar
shave club had also has products for
pretty much everything you need in
the bathroom. Bodywash, Shampoo, hair,
Gel, lip balm, everything at this still
war. There are too many, uh, you know,
out of respect for
Pittsburgh Steeler fans,
I'm not going to read this in a Boston
accent. He always finds a way, kid, sorry.
At the store.
There are too many options and you can't
tell the difference between any of them.
Then if you have any questions to cure,
the clerk usually doesn't know the
difference either or either can't help you
since they're not experts on the products
or they're the only person working on
the fucking floor for a limited time.
Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their shit.
Shower shave starter set to new
members for only $5 to start.
A set features the executive razor and
the three trial versions of their most
popular products that help you stay
fresh and clean, so fresh and so clean.
If your first box in your first box,
you will see received this shave bodywash
and one wipe Choudhary but wipes,
uh, you also receive their executive
razor, which includes their premium,
weighty handle and
focus set of cartridges.
After the first box replacement cartridges
are sent for only a few bucks a month,
this offer is exclusively
available@dollarshaveclub.com slash burp.
That's dollar shave club.com/bar
and if you want a great gift,
give him dollar Shave Club. Uh, give
him dollar shave club. No, sorry.
They've got a super single gift
memberships and eat giftcards dollar shave
club's high quality products.
We'll have you covered from
face cheeks to butt cheeks.
There is no better time to
try the club and lastly,
but not leastly simply safe.
If you've been thinking
about your home security,
there's no better time to get it then
right now simply faith has put together a
massive security arthel for your home,
a special package handpicked just for you.
It's got entry sensors,
motion sensors,
and glass break sensors.
Everything you need to stop criminals
from ever touching your goddamn home and
right now for the holidays are a friends
and simply thief are giving you an
absolutely incredible offer.
Get $200 off this special
handpicked security package.
It keeps its complete
protection for your home.
Simply safe is already the best value
in home security. There's no contracts,
no commitment,
but right now,
get $200 off this holiday
special security package.
Just go do simply faith bird.com that's
simply safe bird.com to take advantage
of this holiday offer and save $200 on
your simply safe home security system.
Simply safe bird.com. How many fucking
times? Um, all right. Diego senior.
Wasn't that enjoyable?
Was it dangerous?
Did I seem like I was trying to get a
danger reward there and now I'm just being
silly? Okay. It can be so mean sometimes.
Um, Hey, I'm on trait
number three, train them.
Three of them have invisit douche
operation and visit Douche.
My teeth are starting to move.
Um, I have a couple announcements.
Patrice O'neil, if you want an eight, if
you guys want a great, a great gift idea.
Patrice O'neil, uh, comedy benefit,
get two tickets for the person you love
stuff at near Goddamn stocking and come
out and see the show on February 20th at
the New York City Center in Manhattan.
If you don't live in Manhattan,
it's a great excuse to come to New York
City and check it out before the entire
thing becomes a giant bed bath and beyond.
All right,
well what am I up to here?
30 not 40 minutes. All right.
Can you help me out here, Neil with
the uh, yeah, she's sleeping right?
No, she's gotten there. What is she doing?
It looks like she is. She's still
squirming. She thrashed around of that,
but now shit.
All right.
Oh, also Santa Steve, Steve,
SumoMe, the Great Steve [inaudible],
Steve Simone and regular hero are raising
money again this year for children
fighting cancer and their families.
Monday morning podcast's listeners help
raise $15,000 last time around and it
had a huge impact on a lot of families.
Their stories are brutal and every bit
helps. The goal this year is 50 grand.
We'll tweet a link today.
Thank you guys so much.
You've already been ridiculously generous
this year, so thank you very much.
All right. M P three player. All right.
Yet you're going to be annoying.
You know,
and this year you're
going to help me out here.
Sure.
Yeah. Okay. You don't sound too enthused.
Would you like your own microphone?
No, that's okay. How does use yours?
I think it'd be better if you had
your own microphone. Talk to the Pe.
No people from it.
Um,
people describe what
I'm wearing right now.
Bill is wearing a pair of pajamas
that I got him for Christmas,
not last year, but maybe the year
before last year was the last year.
What a pair of pajamas that
had got him last year. Oh,
I don't know what another fight and he
looks like, um, like he's on that show.
My two dads that
I look more my three,
my three dads was no, my two
dads was a porno, wasn't, no,
it wasn't 80 show about a girl who had
two dads for a reason that I can't really
recall for the situation.
Comedy of it.
Maybe her mom died and her mom
wasn't sure which one was her dad.
So they were both her dad
or maybe she was dating one,
but the other one was her dad.
I don't really know,
but it was my two dads
and I used to watch it
sounds like the ges was flying around.
All right. MP three player. I know.
What do you want me for me?
MP three player. Hey Billy.
Red faced very Christmas
dude. Uh, thank you. Uh,
my suggested Merry Christmas to you too.
My suggestion for MP three player is
the Apple Watch I'm trying to get at,
I'm trying to get out of them. I'm
trying to get away from apple. Okay.
Cause I have all this other music and
they just won't recognize it and I buy it
off of them,
but they don't have it.
Okay.
All right. Whatever. I'll listen to you.
I know it's more than an MP three player,
but that's the great thing is you
get so much more for the money.
The big drawback is that you can only
use Bluetooth headphones with it.
That's the thing about
app and let me guess,
only Bluetooth headphones made by
fucking apple. Other than that,
I liked that it stays
strapped to your wrist,
so you don't need to carry
anything else with you. Uh,
if you've got the series
three with the Elta,
sounds like a giant commercial for
this thing. Uh, but I, you know,
I did ask the series three
with LTE a doubles as a phone.
What he talked to your risks
like fucking captain Kirk.
The call time is very limited.
I'm not doing this.
Why would I do this? I'm just,
okay friend who smells like anus.
Hell boy. Hey, you redheaded Mick bastard.
Um, I don't give a shit. What are
you going to do? I don't want to.
What about the thing I told you?
What do you think about that? Were,
you know Matt Damon commented on,
that's the stuff going on in Hollywood.
So this person wrote an article
about him and they go, Matt Damon,
a white male Blahblahblahblahblah like,
it was just like, Oh, who doesn't know?
He's a white guy. Like what
does that mean? It means,
and maybe he should
shut as big white SRAP.
Is that not race baiting?
That's like some fox new shit.
There was no reason to say what his race
was or his sex was there and the person,
there was nothing. Anything else
add? They just said that the,
he was a white male and then they just
continued on with the fucking thing.
It's fucking, this is such a, it's,
I swear to God watching, I dunno.
It's just I don't get,
if you just going to,
if you just just say, listen on now,
now it's my turn to be a Douche.
Then I'm fine with it,
but don't fuck it.
Act like you're a better person
because you're not. I mean that's,
that's a fucked up.
I mean you keep
what he's looking at me like you can't,
you can't fucking go two wrongs
don't make a right. Nothing.
What do you mean two wrongs
don't make a right. That's total.
That's fucking race baiting.
Raise baiting and who?
All stereotypes above fucking with his
whole thing about sexual harassment raise
meeting is the same as someone's a
white male. How has that raised baiting?
This is so funny.
I sound like a black person right now
and you sound like a white person.
What always said was says he was just
white. I don't understand what you mean.
Call somebody what they
are. A white male. Oh,
you're saying that if this was like
Fox News they'd be no, this is no,
this is what they were
doing. Tyrrell Jackson. Oh,
black male was spotted at the Bubba.
I like the way they do that type of shit.
I'm saying the reason that they added
that detail was because he was commenting
on sexual harassment and white guys
positions of power in all of that.
So what they was saying in there
is they just say white males.
So then you can go with all your
stereotypes and be like, oh,
totally privileged enough to work
for shit in a position of power.
He doesn't understand this.
Like all this negative shit where
it was no longer Matt Damon.
It was hashtag white male trash. That's
what the fucking guy was doing. Or woman,
whoever wrote that fucking article.
That's what bugged me.
Whether you agreed with what he said
or not is a completely different thing,
but I just,
it just was like,
what the fuck does anyone who the fuck
doesn't know Matt Damon's a white guy?
No, he's just some, and they had
a fucking picture of them anyways.
If he was some complete nobody.
I see the picture.
It was a giant picture
of Matt Damon's Whitehead
and they go, Matt Damon, a white
male. You know what they're doing.
That's that feminist fucking
psycho shit feminist psycho shit.
That fucking psycho shit,
white male trash,
all that shit that they're doing
that literally doing the Sh, not,
not saying all of them are doing it,
but they're doing that
shit where they're there.
They're fighting this thing that
they are literally becoming really,
no, no, no, no. Keep it out.
I'm not talking about what
he said. I'm talking about.
That fucking detail was fucking weird.
Just throw on there. Matt Damon Cama,
Matt Damon, White Male. I was like
male prostitute. It's like what?
I just remembered. What the fuck
does that have to do with anything?
And then I'd read the art, the
gist of the article. I'm like, Oh,
oh I see why you threw that in there.
Cause I mean he's speaking like a
typical white guy. So yeah, it was,
wow, look at that. Look at these all.
Look at always getting thrown around.
Well why you Nia?
You know how they are.
You know how those white guys are
where you feel like I am Sikh,
I secretly hate people.
No, no, no. I'm just,
I'm actually in a way enjoying this shit.
Why?
Because of all that. Hey white guys
are evil and blah, blah, blah, blah,
and I just know to human beings
who have too much fucking power.
I would agree with that.
And when you have too much power as a
nation or as a fucking race or a sex,
you stent you 10 it's very hard to
not overstep. You bounce. Right. Okay.
And what I am now seeing is the pendulum
is changing is that people that what I
always felt as people just,
they're going to behave the same way.
It's not going to become better.
It's just somebody else will then get
in power and then behave the exact same
fucking way while they pat them on selves
on the back saying how great they are,
like white guys who did a bunch of
horrific shit and then put up statues of
themselves. Does that make sense?
Hmm. That's an interesting point.
Ooh, ouch. All right friend
who smells like anus,
your beard is like kind of
out of control right now,
don't you? She come over here
like it's a little bushy,
isn't it? Yeah. What's the, what's
going on? What's a, what's a,
what's a happen and hot
stuff that's racist. Um,
did, um, did dollar shave club
not hook you up this morning?
I Dunno.
I just like fucking Robinson Caruso.
It was funny. I've heard that name my
whole life. I don't even know who that is.
Then you get stuck on an island or was he
like, uh, I think so. I don't even know.
Oh, we've got to look it up. No. Something
from literature. It's a, it's a book. Oh,
there you go. There's your
quote for the week. Everybody.
It's something from literature. That's
what I married and made a child with.
It's something from literature shipwreck.
It's some white dude probably
trying to explore some island.
Robinson Caruso a white man.
Yeah.
Trying to act like he discovered some
shit when people were already lived there.
That's probably what it was. All
right. I go with all of that.
I had a big argument. Somebody bought
that about what? Oh, about the whole,
you can't discover some shit with people
who are already there and this guy
actually argue with me. He goes, well,
he was discovering it for himself.
And the people didn't know, but it's
just like, no, he's a dog for Columbus.
I forget who he was talking
about. Yeah, cause fuck that guy.
What did he fuck that guy? Fuck
that guy. Fuck Christopher Columbus.
If he didn't call me out, you,
you wouldn't have met me. Wow.
Really? Listen, knit. You know, to make
an Omelet, you've got to break a few eggs.
Things that come out of your mouth. Oh
fucking deal. Nia adults, listen to this.
They know I'm fucking around Jesus.
Fucking Christ the consult.
They will take that clip and what you will
see, the trouble I get in that, that's,
that's a classic one for Huffington
Post. Fucking Douche bags. The,
we'll clip that out of it. Oh, those low
hanging fruit douche bags. All right.
Robinson Caruso.
So cross out the way it's spelled.
C R U s s e Robinson Crusoe.
Everyone says Robinson Caruso,
but it looks like Crusoe.
So cause I always think of Rick Caruso,
um,
first published on the 25th of April 17,
19.
The first edition is Bubba plot summary.
Jesus,
let's get to the cliff notes.
Oh God, this is too long. Crusoe
joins an expedition to bring slaves
from Africa, but he's chick. Yeah.
Who gives a fuck about this guy?
But he was shipwrecked moving on in
his dorm. Exactly what I thought.
That's exactly what I thought. No,
no, no. It was about that. Nah.
Did they do a second version where
that wasn't in there? Oh God, no.
They make it. They make 'em out
like he's some fucking hero though.
Dante cannibals,
discover NAO cannibals and island.
Kill and eat president. Oh
God. You know what? Yeah.
I don't give a shit.
It's for his arrival there.
Olin only he and three animals.
The captain's dog and two cats survived
the shipwreck. Overcoming his despair.
He fetches arms,
tools and supplies.
So basically white people read this,
ignore the slavery part and then
root for this white guy to come home.
Cause Yeah. Put themselves in
that place. What did they venture?
Yeah.
How did we get on this subject of that
guy? Oh, you said my beard, right?
Because I said your beard. It
was too much. All right. Well,
the three months were the three
musketeers, Robinson, Caruso.
Christopher Columbus,
Matt Damon White males was,
it wasn't a white males that
really needs to shut the fuck up.
Why do they need to shut the fuck up?
That's such an ignorant statement. Ignite.
It isn't near.
You can't want,
if you tell people to shut the fuck up
and then not going to listen to your
point that like what you just said there
is how people try and communicate in
the Internet where they start
things off with, hey shit, Dick,
maybe if you fucking didn't have your
head up your ass and they could actually
be making a good point,
but they started that way.
If you tell people that they need
to shut the fuck up and then what?
Listen to you,
what?
What sort of human being is going to
be receptive to what you have to say if
that's the way you're going,
you're dipping into the pool.
That is because I'm thinking about
other things that Matt Damon has said.
Other like sort of stands is that he's
taken and I just feel like he is really
arrogant and he's not really as worldly
and understands people as well as he
thinks that he does and he's in a very
like small little bubble and I'm just,
I'm not here.
You've never met this guy.
And I guarantee if you went to a Christmas
party out there and he was there,
you'd be like, Oh my
God, Matt Damon's here.
Maybe a couple of years ago I would have,
oh Jesus Christ.
Everybody needs to just fucking just,
just,
just relax a little bit. This is where
my problem was. Like first of all,
this wasn't even about that. This
wasn't even about what the fuck he said.
What it was about was that that fucking
person says Matt Damon, White Male,
a white male. I'm just saying
that's all I'm talking about.
I don't give a fuck about
all of that other shit.
I'm trying to stay out of that shit. No
you don't. But I'm trying to say why I,
but that's a whole other thing having to
do with project greenlight and the last
season and the way he was. All right.
Oh, come Dick. What are you doing? Geez.
He's already getting enough fucking shit.
You can throw more crap on the fire.
I mean, I'm sure you want to
do a movie with him Monday. No,
that's not what I'm saying.
Hey,
I'm not trying
you such,
you're such an asshole on this.
Why did I invite you when?
That's not why I'm saying that now.
You made me look like a fucking asshole.
Hollywood phone.
Stop trying to get into bed
with all these guys. I'm not,
that's not the point of any of this.
First of all, near he's not in,
but this is the thing. This is the thing
that every dumb mistake people think of,
you get to know the actor. They're going
to get you in the movie. They're not.
They're not.
That's not how that works.
They're trying to keep their
own fucking head above water.
They don't have fucking time for you
and can I play your fucking postman?
They don't give a shit. All right. Jesus
fucking Christ. I got to tell you any,
you're killing it on this podcast cause
every time I try to make a fucking point,
you trash me in such a way that just
destroys anything. I'm trying to say.
I'm just saying, I'm just,
you know, Jesus Christ.
I can't look,
I can't make fun of the Huffington Post
and then get somebody else in trouble
for some, some bullshit. They
already got in trouble for that.
That's what I'm saying. I'm leaving
it alone. Okay. I'm leaving it alone.
Fuck all right friend who smells
like anus for the 90th fucking time.
I'll tell you, I think you're banned
from this podcast. Can I read it?
Yeah, go ahead. You read it. Thank you.
[inaudible] big fan of the podcast.
My friend and I saw you and Mr. Don't
forget this part. You already read that.
Hey, you redheaded Mick
bastard. That's offensive.
Now somebody is going to take that.
Someone's going to take that and cut
out the part where you said that's
offensive. I just wanted you on tape
saying, Hey, you redheaded Mick bastard.
I love it. All right.
Big Fan of the podcast.
My friend and I saw you
and Mister [inaudible] do
standup in Albany, New York.
Phenomenal show.
My question is about women's hygiene.
Oh boy.
My two buddies and I have a friend that
has a very nice person and he was very
preppy clothing. However, [inaudible],
however she smells like
a bag of rotten clams.
The odor has become so bad that the three
of us have questioned whether wearing
a guests about questioned,
whether wearing a gas max around her as
a person needs to write better as men.
We know it is not right to tell
a woman she's smells like ass,
but we don't know what else to do.
Should we tell her or con one of her
friends and to telling her, thanks bill.
Keep up the hilarious podcast and
go fuck yourself. First of all,
you are so unoriginal by being like
she smelled like a bag of rotten clams,
you know, clams. Poussey
um, second of all,
if you're not fucking this broad, no,
you don't have anything to say next.
All right. Nia got a
little defensive. Nick,
can I ask you a question?
If you walked around smelling
like a bag of rotten clams,
wouldn't you want somebody to give you
the heads up before you became a very
preppy clothing? However she smells
like, what does that have to do with?
And I don't, I don't get it. Oh cause
she's nice and she wears nice clothes,
but she smells like clams.
A bag of rotten clamps,
a bag of rotten clams. This sounds
like an exaggeration. Give me a break.
Smell so bad. The three of
us have questioned whether
wearing a gas. Why are you,
why you matter what? Like where's the
rest of your sentence? First of all,
learn how to write a sentence properly.
Then maybe I can hear you getting
so defensive. Like they said,
you smell like a bag of rotten clamps.
This is this fucking thing.
You just defending this
person because she's a,
you inserted yourself from the story and
you would be the person I'm supposed to
put myself in the scenario.
I guess so.
So now what I'm trying to do is I'm
trying to help pull you out of it and say
that you in no way, shape, shape, or
form, smell like a bag of and clamps,
um, edgy tonight. All right, fine. Okay.
Uh, so what would you
say, how can they tell her
all right, this, this, this woman. Okay.
Probably wants to find love at some
point and you, you're not going to,
you're really limiting.
You know,
she's got to find somebody that works
in some sort of chemical plant that's
destroyed his sense of smell.
So I got some sort of medical issue.
Yeah.
Sometimes you could have like literally
a sinus infection that can give you a
really bad breath.
There's all kinds of stuff like,
um,
you know,
and this is a thing like guys,
like,
it's not like I'd never ran
into a woman that didn't,
wasn't so fresh and so clean,
you know, and I, there's no
way to tell him cause it,
the embarrassment of it,
which they do. Singing,
telegram,
you smell.
Um,
how can they do that?
I would actually, uh, I would,
I would actually think that she needs,
if she's dressing nice and all that
type of stuff, meaning she's clean,
I would say that she probably needs to
see a doctor and it's probably something
with their diet. I'm just, this is
just shit that I've heard diet. Uh,
or I don't know, maybe she's
stressing a lot. I have no idea.
But I honestly don't know how would handle
that. Well, how would you handle it?
Okay. If they, it's,
it's like the end of a Tom Cruise movie
and you've got to clip the right fucking
wire. It blows up in your face.
Okay. First, first thought.
I how you doing it? I
think you, you're taking,
you take the mouth not on like a day, but
just hang out and just be like, listen,
I love you so much. You are such an
amazing person. You are the best.
You're the best. Yeah. You breaking
up with me. Um, no, no, no, no.
I just feel like, you know,
sometimes I just noticed like,
like an odor coming from you.
So I don't know. I don't know if
like, I don't know if like
you're, you're, you're Washington
gene isn't working,
you know?
Or like why would she put a
vagina and a washing machine?
They're not smelling her vagina.
They're smelling her be, oh, right.
Well, when I heard clams, I thought the
problem was in the basement accolade.
Exactly. They're talking about
her B o I would assume. Oh,
but we could be halitosis. It could be
if you're not, if you're not fucking,
or like what do you, what do you care?
You know, but because they liked her,
they want to hang out with them, but
she smells like fucking, and I'm sorry,
he said a bag of clamps. I don't want to
tell you. She smells like low tide there.
Yeah. Maybe. Oh, maybe you're washing,
your washing machine isn't working
effectively or you should try a different,
uh, I know what I would do.
Detergent. What would you do?
I get to those spray aerosol cans of
like deodorant and I dress like a cowboy.
I walk into the bar and go heads up.
And when she did it go,
sorry, you got nothing. I don't
know. I would try to have,
uh,
I w I would have,
I would talk to a female friend of hers
and tell her to do it because it'll be
less embarrassing and just say
you just given him the heads up.
That's a friend.
And uh,
I still have this friend and we
had someone that we worked with,
someone who I'm actually still friends
with and said a white male. Yeah.
And he would talk about how
my friends breath stank.
And I would always like laugh
because he was right. Her,
her breath did stink a lot and I would
always offer her gum, gum, mints. Oh,
you want one? Do you want one? And
she would always refuse. So it's like,
what can I do? You have to
sit her down and say, bitch,
you state doesn't sing anymore.
But at the time,
because probably somebody told
her. Yeah, probably. All right dad,
cheating on mom.
Dear Billy skank
please do not say my name now.
He's got a jokey name.
He's got a jokey ne.
Why are you such a drag?
All of a sudden one fucking stinky
clamp thing and no, come on man.
Like nup. Yeah, sorry. Sorry everybody.
I should be in a bad mood the way
you've been trashed me on this.
I invite you on them onto my show.
I already lost Sherry's berries.
They're walking out of my life and
then I got to listen to you trashed me.
All right. I had been a fan of yours
since the year 2000. I remember that.
How great was that bit?
I fucking love that bit.
CONAN O'Brien show everybody.
I love hearing your podcast every week.
I use it as it as an escape,
as an escape from my shitty life. Um,
I want to ask you for your advice,
but a month ago I started to notice
my father would talk to a coworker who
happens to be a lady.
I didn't think much,
much of it seeing as how he's been
happily married for the past 27 years.
I checked my dad's phone number,
my phone the other day.
He usually has me fix his phone since
he doesn't understand technology.
Upon checking his phone,
I saw a couple of texts and a picture
that they have been sending each other.
Oh,
all right. A couple of texts. I
don't know what it was in the text.
I don't know what the picture was.
And he doesn't need to be sending pictures
of themselves to another woman. Yeah.
I don't know what to do.
I have looked up this guy for 25 years.
Oh No. Now I feel crushed.
Sing. The piece of Shitty is,
should I confront him and tell him to
stop or else I'll tell my mother. Bill,
can you please help me thank you and
go fuck yourself from Adolph Stalin.
Ooh,
just in time for Christmas.
Uh,
what would you do?
Okay.
What would you do,
Babe?
What would you do if you had to give
your lab freedom? What will you do?
Um, I dunno what I would
do. I would, I would,
uh,
just say I was the,
you know,
I was fixing your phone the other day
and I saw this picture of this woman.
Who is she? I would do it.
There you go. You probably lie.
Just know that he's probably
going to lie to you. I mean,
you can confront him and just say,
hey, like what Skype was, you know,
you had me fix your phone.
I saw these pictures and these tax like,
what's going on? He's probably going
get upset. Why are you reading my tail?
I didn't ask you to do that.
I just asked you to get me off airplane
mode or whatever the fuck it is that he,
he did, you know, why are you
looking right? Ron, Ron, Ron, Ron,
he's probably going to get really,
really upset with you and he's going to
lie and he's going to deny it and then
he's going to be probably overly
sweet to your mom in front of you.
Um, I dunno, but your, um,
up to this guy for 25 years now.
Yeah.
It's a hard thing to realize that your
parents are not as perfect and great and
upstanding as you thought.
They were not suck.
So what you think he should just go up
and ask them? I mean, if it's mine, yeah,
he should just say like, Hey, I just
saw these pictures. Like, you know,
I don't know what they were,
but I thought they were maybe
something inappropriate,
but maybe I'm wrong and it's just
been bothering me. But like I said,
just maybe that will make them stop,
be prepared that he is going
to get very pissed at you.
He might not, he might be fucking
embarrassed. I don't know.
And it's, it's probably gonna make him
be really upset and yell at him. So,
but I feel bad for your mom.
That's the thing. But who knows?
Maybe your parents have an
arrangement that you don't know.
Uh,
oh
Jesus. I don't know. You got to consider
all the possibilities here, you know?
But unless his mom's at home, just baking
cookies and making dinner every night,
you know, and being like, oh,
she's just nagging him every night.
You just get sick of it. Maybe she's
banging in the mail, man. Hey, you know,
can we have a little sympathy for the guy
fucking wrote in here? Jesus Christ.
I would go with her first advice.
All right. Over. Okay. Overrated.
Underrated. It's back. All right.
Overrated.
Outdoor hockey games.
I've been twice one in Comerica Park in
Detroit and another at the big house.
It's cold. You can't see the whole
ice and it's hard to track the puck.
Not to mention the blinding glare
from the sun. Do yourself a favor.
Save your money and watch
it at home. Wow. Um,
underrated homemade French fries. Huh? Uh,
if you're hosting a barbecue or
just making burgers for the family,
take the time and make some hand cut
fries at the beginning of one of your
advertisers.
Double Fry them and toss and sea salt.
[inaudible] if you're feeling really
ambitious, a homemade spicy ketchup,
we'll put it over the top. Wow. Nice.
Your grand rapid show at the church
was great. Can't wait to hear it.
Those jokes again. And your next
special. I love that fucking,
that's such a great
gig. Um, all right. Uh,
advice
lady.
Is this the last one? It's a long,
it's a long one. Brace yourselves.
Bill's going to be reading for a while.
22 year old.
Married to a 47 year old.
Oh boy.
Bad idea. I'm calling it right
now, but go ahead. All right.
I had been putting off email you this
because I feel pretty embarrassed,
but I adore your podcasts,
your honest advice and I have massive,
massive respect for you. So fuck it. Uh,
if you do actually read this and take the
time to respond and thank you so much.
I Dunno why, but I actually love
when somebody uses the word adore.
I adore your podcasts. It seems so much
more sincere than I love your podcast.
But now that I put that out there,
everyone's going to make fun of
me and say how much they adore a,
I should probably start by saying that
I was in a really bad spot when I first
met my guy.
I was 20 and he was 45.
I lost my mom when I
was 17 of lung cancer.
And then I lost the mother figure who
had taken me in and I had stayed with for
two years again to lug cancer.
Jesus Christ.
I never knew my dad. Oh,
you knew that was coming.
So I know there's some daddy
issues in to play here probably.
But anyways,
I felt like a giant curse to of my family
members became ill and I was falling
behind. In my degree. The only
happiness I had was going to concerts,
getting high and trying to forget
my grief in the music. Yeah,
that sounds like what I would've done.
That wasn't until I met my guy at one
of the shows and everything started
changing for the better. He had
the most amazing, confident,
positive energy I had ever seen and I
felt so unbelievably happy just by being
around him.
We started dating.
I fell in love hard and fast forward nine
months later we got married in a Vegas
in Vegas on a trip visiting his
family as he's American. I was drunk.
The marriage is not registered in the
UK and my family still doesn't know.
Please don't judge me. I would
never judge you. I'm a fucking mess.
Everything is mostly wonderful between
us and we have lived together for a year
now.
He's a roadie and will typically spend a
couple of months touring and then three
months at home in that cycle
he is 100% trustworthy.
I liked that dynamic we have,
because I get my own time to
focus on my freelance work.
But the time of park keeps
the love fresh and exciting,
especially as we travel a
lot when he is off to work,
uh, before, before the baby. Right. Uh,
but he wants to start breeding within a
couple of years and whilst he is someone
I would start a family with, I know
I'm not ready for anything like that.
We've spoken about this and he
said he would wait a few years,
but I still know I'm not going
to be ready in a few years.
I still feel like a lost
teenager most of the time.
I know what the responsibility, so I
know what the responsible thing to do is,
which is to end it.
But he's been,
the reason the last couple of years in
my life had been so much brighter and
happier than they have in so long.
He's great in bed.
Super thoughtful and generous.
No, it isn't a sugar daddy thing,
but it's nice having someone
wants to look after you.
I just don't know what to do at all.
I really don't want to lose him,
but he's 47 now and once
kids as soon as possible.
I don't want to be a cunt and knowingly
waste his time. I do have a good Chase's.
Okay.
Two more paragraphs.
I do have a good circle of friends that
I'll be absolutely fine alone slash.
Single,
but I just don't want to regret throwing
away a good relationship over this. Ps,
I'm so glad you liked Manchester.
We loved you here.
I fucking loved going to Manchester.
I had a great time and I would love to
go to Liverpool and new and a new castle.
I would like to do more of those cities
up there a next time I come over.
We'd love to meet you and the beautiful
Nia in England one day just so I can
shake the hand and thank you in person
for making a post uni existential crisis
so much more bearable. I don't even know
what that means. Huh? Stay shiny and
go fuck yourself. Um, all right. Look,
you've been through a lot of shit.
Okay.
And you married this guy nine months in.
It's not what what he wants is not
what you want and here's the deal.
Okay.
As much as you're going to feel like
you're an asshole for doing this to this
guy. What kind of a fucking 45 year
old guy marries a 20 year old boy.
He's 47 now and she's 22 yeah,
but w and last,
the like knock her up right away and
all that other kind of stuff. Yeah.
I mean he, yeah. How do you not know that
that's coming? Yeah. I mean, she didn't,
she's young. You know what I'm saying? How
does he know that this isn't coming? Oh,
I don't know. I mean, I just feel like he
is like on, you know, the middle and age.
He's a middle age and so he's freaking
is not middle aged. He's over the hill.
I'm so sick of people saying 47 why
isn't that Middle Age 47 times to come on
artists? What is it? Um, 94 yeah.
How many people make it the 94 not a lot.
Like 94 people make it to 94.
Yeah,
like 35 is middle aged 35 times two is 70.
You have to be,
um, you'd have to be true to
yourself. You're so young,
you don't want to have
kids now because yeah,
your life is going to change Jurassic
Lee and you haven't had a chance to even
fully, you know, experience everything
that you want to experience your, your,
your weights. A young people
of course have kids at your
age, but you're so young,
so you know, you should just be
honest with him about it and you know,
I'll wait a couple of can't have kids.
You don't know if you don't know who
you are or what the fuck you're doing.
You can't have kids.
And honestly,
it's not your fault that he
waited this long to, you know,
be in a relationship and have kids like,
and sometimes you have to be selfish
to get what you want. Okay. That's it.
Okay. You're being, you're
being a good know. She just
takes off now. He's still 47.
You can meet a fucking 31 year old.
Yeah. That's who he needs to meet.
A chick in her thirties who's
just sweating it out going,
what the fuck I need a baby DiMauro.
I need to trap a man. That's,
that's what he's, it's not your fault.
He's drafting this late in life.
He's drafted in the later rounds.
That's what's left. You know that,
you know the trap car. Know what he's
talking about. He's, he's going to,
he's going to date these going to date,
the female version of that.
They got this fucking thing
out there called the trap car.
Speaking of racist. They drive
it in what? They drive this car,
a nice car. They leave it running
with the keys on and they,
but they only do it in like
non white neighborhoods. Yeah.
It's such bullshit. Bullshit.
Um, but anyway, don't, um,
don't have a, maybe just to keep
this guy because you will end up,
you'll love your baby and
you'll end up hating him,
but you'll resent your baby cause she
didn't get to go to fucking Joshua tree
and eat mushrooms and do whatever the
fuck he supposed to do in your early
twenties. Whatever. What our kids do
now in their early twenties. Yeah.
You guys are really at
completely different stages in
your life. And this is why,
you know,
unfortunately it's not advisable to
marry someone who could literally be your
father.
So Nia with another cold bucket of water.
I liked this. I liked this Rainer. She
is sweet and you know, I don't know.
It sucks.
You know what I mean?
She sounds like she's genuinely in love
with him and it doesn't want to break up,
but this is a pretty big issue.
This isn't a little thing.
So He's,
by the time you're ready,
he's going to be dead. And I'm just
kidding. Um, he's going to be, you know,
even older. So it was
just, yeah, I dunno. Yeah.
Or you could like adapt a Twat. I
told you so. But you had to say,
I feel like you're all you over
selling it. No, I'm done. I'm quiet.
Did a great job in the podcast media
people feel like it was going to love and
you trashed me two times.
You gave me like the trashing of the
year twice on one fucking podcast.
That's cool.
I can live with that.
I always know when there's
something going on with you.
I always know there's
I don't know what the fuck
it is when you do that,
because I'm always right because
I'm always right. Knee and leg, man.
It was going on with you.
I'm fine. You're not.
You're a, you're a fucking mess. You're,
you're freaking out about the holidays.
I know. You are. All right. That's it.
That's a podcast. That's the podcast.
Ladies and gentleman, that
is the podcast. Bill Burr,
a white male signing off with Nia.
Nia Hill, a black female. Alright.
Have a great couple of days. Uh, I'll
check in on. How about them apples?
Perfect. You're crushing
it. All right, I'll see you.